uh today's topic is going to be a little
bit different from what we do typically
we're going to use an interesting data
set in my opinion it comes from the
heart disease survey conducted by the
cdc
and it's also a project on kaggle if
anyone is familiar with this portal
where you can find a lot of machine
learning competitions and different
kinds of data sets
so first of all i will try to give you a
conceptual overview of what we are going
to try to do today and how
and then we'll kind of dig a little bit
deeper into the actual methods and
how you can probably get started with
this kind of analysis keeping in mind
that the same approaches are going to be
useful
not only for this kind of data but
really any kind of data that you come
across now what is different about this
particular data set from the typical
data sets that you will find on the
portal for example
is that this is a survey and the survey
is typically not numeric so we'll talk a
little bit about encoding
it is also different from omics data and
a lot of times you will find these
tutorials on our portal for example for
transcriptomics data or metagenomics
data or other
structured data sets
and
they have a very specific property omics
data sets do
the property is that the number of
samples is much less than the number of
features
and in this case it's the other way
around you have a lot more samples
individuals and less features less
questions that they that that are being
used in this analysis
so without further ado let's get started
so what is heart disease heart disease
is the leading cause of death of men and
women since 1921
and
it is
together with stroke accounts for about
40 percent of all deaths
one person dies every 36 seconds in the
u.s from heart disease which means that
during this workshop a number of
individuals are going to unfortunately
pass away and not only that this disease
also costs over
360 billion last year which means that
this is a very expensive problem to
treat
now to understand
how we can address this pressing and
significant need or burden we need to
try to understand what kinds of factors
lead to heart disease or what are
typically
the lifestyle behaviors um or
predisposition such as diabetes
that actually leads to heart disease
so we hope that the goal of this
workshop will be twofold number one know
that there's a high risk of every one of
us getting developing heart disease and
we need to be aware of what those risks
are
number two you will be able to use data
from
a
significant sizable uh representative
population
to know that it's not only
for you but you know for people around
you as well
what is this data set so this is the
2020 annual cdc survey
which has about 400 000 adults in the
u.s
and the survey was conducted to identify
health factors that are common among
people that have heart disease so
there's two major groups there's people
that have heart disease and there's
people that don't have heart disease and
by comparing them we can find
interesting patterns what types of
features or observations do we have
well obviously we have heart disease yes
or no so people that have
coronary heart disease or myocardial
infarction
are the people who are considered to be
with heart disease and then people that
don't have those two conditions don't
have heart disease then there's bmi
which is the body mass index which takes
account your size as well as how much
you wage so it's kind of a proportionate
measure
smoking which in this case um
if you have smoked at least 100
cigarettes in your entire life
you are considered to be uh you know a
smoker so it doesn't mean that you are
actively smoking today
alcohol drinking heavy drinkers so adult
men have more than 14 drinks per week or
adult women having more than seven
drinks per week are considered to be
yes for alcohol drinking or if you have
less than that then you're considered to
be no
stroke is if you ever had a stroke in
your life physical health
how
well you move but also
your physical illness or injury
and this is a subjective kind of an
evaluation that you evaluate on yourself
mental health
so what again could it be in the past 30
days
difficulty of walking if you have
serious difficulty walking or climbing
stairs
sex or male or female and then different
types of age categories so all of this
data there's a lot more data to the
actual data set you can find the full
data set on the cdc website but what we
are going to be doing is we are going to
take a clean depth version of this data
set in other words something that was a
little bit curated and adapted for the
needs of data analysis
this cleaned up data again this can be
found on kaggle but this cleaned up data
as you can see is standardized right and
so because it is standardized now we can
kind of try to see what are the
proportions of individuals in this
survey all together that fall into
different categories based on these
different features
for example people that do have heart
disease are only nine percent out of
this population and people that don't
have heart disease are 91 percent
what does that tell us
that actually points to the main point
of today's message and the main point
that we want you to take away from this
workshop today is that this is a highly
imbalanced data set and imbalanced data
sets introduce a specific
challenge for machine learning right
because we have so many examples of
people who are kind of in the no
category right they don't have heart
disease and a much smaller
representation of people that do have
heart disease
and because as we all know individuals
are very different
even though they might have or not have
heart disease all kinds of other factors
could change significantly
we have less information to train our
model
using
this kind of data about heart disease
individuals than individuals that don't
have heart disease and that is a
challenge that we're going to try to
look at
now the analysis objectives or the
objectives from this workshop for you we
hope that you will be able to number one
understand how to deal with public
health survey data surveys are a common
way to try to evaluate different risk
factors and different things that you
can
study about the population but we'll see
how effective these
methods are and what are some
considerations that you should have when
you deal with survey data
number two we'll talk about the role of
exploratory analysis and how it's useful
and what kinds of insights you might get
from what's called exploratory analysis
or summarizing the data and exploring
different patterns
we'll talk about different types of
machine learning and we'll talk about
supervised and unsupervised methods
methods like clustering and
classification but we'll also talk about
when and how they are useful and why
would we use one or the other in a
specific situation
we'll then talk about specifically about
different methods of clustering and i
think this is also important here
because as we look at the data and we
look at how this data could be uh
summarized we'll see how different
methods of clustering are more or less
useful to discover patterns and noise in
the data that we have
then we'll talk about how to perform
clustering evaluate clustering and how
to apply a classification and evaluate
classification so important kind of
concepts for anyone who is going to rely
on machine learning to draw insights
from data analysis
and then we'll specifically talk about
this challenge for unbalanced data
what kinds of uh kind of methods do we
have to make sure that the training and
the test and the validation are actually
possible even though our data is biased
right it is not representative
of an equal kind of proportion of each
category
and here you have i think an image that
summarizes it well
we can imagine that this is a principle
component or some kind of a
two-dimensional plot that actually shows
us these two different groups let's say
zero are people that don't have heart
disease and one are people that do have
heart disease right and you have a clear
distinction between these two groups but
nevertheless it might be challenging to
draw the exact line between them because
there's overlap and because there's this
overlap
immediately you might start thinking
well who are the people at the
intersection right are these people that
could have heart disease but they're
actually not classified as people with
heart disease for example they never
went to a doctor
to determine this condition
or
maybe there are people that do have a
heart disease that are not that sick
right maybe they had heart disease but
they fully recovered right and then how
can we take these kinds of insights and
kind of develop some ideas or hypotheses
that we could actually test and discover
uh specifically in a data set like this
now we are going to use
python in this particular
workshop
even though you could use r and you
could use even excel for some of these
things and there are many different
tools out there that you could actually
use to perform such analysis but in the
context of the limited time that we have
together today we hope that you will get
a pretty solid introduction to python
and one important package in python
called sklearn or site kit learn a
package that is going to be very useful
for anyone dealing with conventional
machine learning applications and
evaluation
we'll also talk about two different
methods of visualization
matplotlib and plotly matplotlib is
actually a very useful library of
visualization a library that is embedded
into sklearn and made very useful and
user-friendly i would say for anyone who
is
used to coding with python
and plotly
is a specific package that is used for
interactive data visualization so we'll
see how this interactivity helps us
extract more insights quicker
than when we use more static
visualization
finally we'll talk about several
different specific
data science tools that you will be
exposed to today
we'll talk about encoding so as i
mentioned this is a data set that
contains
uh
such answers like yes or no right and so
we obviously want to convert those to
integers because most machine learning
methods are designed to work with
numeric data so we'll talk about
different kind of uh
approaches to encoding
correlation and analysis
ultimately
relationships between data sets and
numbers could be measured in different
ways and we'll talk about one of those
ways which is correlation but we'll also
talk about
variance and and that is a feature that
is going to be used in the principal
component analysis part of today's
workshop then we'll talk about different
methods of clustering
kind of standard low-dimensional methods
like k-means and hierarchical clustering
and a little bit more advanced
density-based methods like db scan
we'll then talk about different
approaches to classification and why we
have different approaches to
classification many different methods
exist and we'll kind of learn about two
approaches svm or support vector
machines and random forest a variation
of decision trees but we'll also briefly
touch on this aspect of automl right how
can we kind of test many different
approaches and find one that works best
and then finally we'll talk about the
specific uh objective of today's
workshop which is to try and work
with our model to make it more balanced
and how does that affect how does that
affect
the outcomes right our ability to get a
better
more balanced uh training and test data
set so that we can get better insights
now before i jump into
the topics that i just mentioned let me
briefly mention that this is a part of
the omixlogic data science training
program so as sonalika already mentioned
we have a lot of asynchronous resources
as well as the mentor-guided program
that you can participate in that will
allow you to gain
hands-on skills and exposure to a
variety of omics-based data science
projects that you can leverage to
improve your career
and we hope that anyone if you have a
background in biology biotechnology
medicine or others would be able to gain
those skills as well and that is why we
made a lot of those tools easily
accessible we've made simple to follow
tutorials and we allow you a whole
set of features to
perform the analysis but also develop a
project of your own using our portal
called omixlogic
now on this portal you will find these
practical step-by-step tutorials that
will cover most of the things that we
will speak about today including how to
load data manipulate visualize and
analyze your data using statistical
methods perform dimensionality reduction
and so forth so most of the topics that
we cover today are going to be also
explained in a very step-by-step manner
inside of these courses and there you
will find courses both in python and in
r as well as user friendly methods for
example methods on the t by info
platform
in addition to that you will find
curated data sets so today we're using
the cdc heart disease data but there you
will find other interesting data sets
such as modeling cancer precision
medicine or analysis of the cancer
genome atlas liver cancer risk
evaluation and many other examples as
well
okay
so before we go on does anyone have any
questions let me check the chat box
okay so someone is asking i wanted to
know whether you have any portal for
peptide design as therapeutics in your
courses we actually have a very specific
program
designed specifically around structural
biology
so please
share those links in the chat if you may
specific to virology as well so sonalika
maybe you could
add that information in the chat
we will have this webinar recorded so
you're welcome to review the webinar
recording after we are done so i see
some question about that
and i see other people that are saying
i'm interested in translational oncology
uh so that is great so uh if you're
interested in oncology as i mentioned we
have a number of projects
and those that are interested in
precision medicine precision oncology
any kind of molecular data this is
exactly uh kind of the emphasis of our
training typically
and i do want to mention that we have a
variety of programs projects and
resources that you can leverage for that
another person is asking
please put emphasis on what these
different analysis signify from a
qualitative point of view i will make
sure to do that as well
will there be a dot pi file given to us
at the end of the webinar well
actually we will have a
full interactive notebook for you to
follow
so we will share that momentarily this
is an introduction to give you a high
level overview of what we will do and
then ragav is going to be able to
take you through the practical things as
well
um
so like as i mentioned if you could
share
the
links to the different programs that we
have about oncology and precision
medicine
that would be great and let me just very
quickly find dr raghavendran
who will be
presenting
soon
but first i will finish my part because
i think it is important
uh to have um
a good understanding of what we're
trying to achieve right uh what are the
actual insights
okay so let me uh briefly go over these
topics before i pass on i know that
everyone is excited and waiting to get
hands-on working with the data finding
all kinds of interesting patterns
so what is the objective of this kind of
analysis so any kind of a data science
project is separated into three major
steps
so at first somebody collected the data
that could come from an experiment that
could come from the real world right
this survey comes from the real world
these are actual individuals that were
surveyed and based on where the data is
coming from you should have an
appropriate kind of assumption about
that
once you get that data that data is
processed right and processing can mean
many different things
in the case of omics data for example
that means maybe compiling all of the
bits and pieces of information into a
single table
in this case we will look at
for example one hard coding
encoding of different methods
so you have yes and no you can convert
that to integer encoding you have
multiple categories you can convert
those to multiple levels and there's
many different ways to do that another
issue could be raw data might have
missing values right so how do you
eliminate those or how do you
fill those in so cleaning that data
organizing that data and structuring
that data typically is that
processing step
then we have this step of exploratory
analysis and exploratory analysis is
really asking the question what kinds of
patterns pop out so what kinds of
patterns could pop out at us we could
find distinct groups or patterns
or
abnormalities anomalies in our data that
is a part of exploratory analysis
how can we find those well we can find
those in two major ways we can visualize
our data using different
standard
tools like proportion right or
statistical features like variants
we could also mine our data right we
could look for more discrete and kind of
interesting patterns in our data and
visualize them so it's really a back and
forth between visualization and data
mining
after we have performed that typically
what we come to
are some well-defined questions for
example if i have people in the heart
disease category and the no heart
disease category how many of each
categories
have
been smoking or using alcohol and is
there a statistical difference
between those two groups based on these
observations
and that is called statistical modeling
and this means that we are trying to
find
a significance that is representative of
the population and that is called
inference so we're actually trying to
infer from the population that we have
something that could be generalized
about everyone right so here we have
four hundred thousand individuals but we
have over you know three four billion
people in the world or maybe even more
now so how can we look at this
population that we have surveyed to
generalize and find some universal
pattern that we think is consistent for
everyone across the board right and that
would describe this
general topic of a disease right like
heart disease and these generalized
topics of smoking drinking bmi
and other health patterns
all right now let's briefly talk about
python so python is a very useful and i
i would say a user-friendly language to
use in your analysis
it might seem difficult for people to
get into it right so i want to briefly
speak about this and explain why python
is a worthwhile investment number one
into your skills in your career for
those of you that already know python
you can pretty much skip these uh next
few slides but if you're new to python i
want to make sure that it is very easy
for you to get started right and i don't
want anyone to think that oh this is
going to be a lot of coding and i'm
going to struggle i don't think so i
think you'll find it enjoyable
we'll try to make sure that every aspect
of what we do is clearly explained and
if you have questions or would like to
learn more we have a series of tutorials
and guided
programs as well that can help you get
gain those skills and use them in the
future
so two specific
things that you need to know about
python number one python is
user-friendly because it has a lot of
packages that people have designed to
make things easy for you for example
there's a whole package of functions in
numpy or pandas that deal with the
structure of data and so we'll use a lot
of those to be able to prepare the data
for our analysis
let's now talk about exploratory data
analysis so how can we look at this
particular data and again you will jump
into the hands-on portion in just a few
more minutes but so that you understand
each stage and what you're expecting to
get out of that stage let me give you an
idea of what you will find
so first of all exploratory data
analysis as i mentioned is just to ask
simple questions right how can my data
be divided into groups and what can
those groups tell me about the different
population members or representatives
that i have here
as we mentioned there's about nine
percent of people that have heart
disease and about 91 of people that
don't have heart disease and that makes
it an imbalanced data set
there's about 60 percent smokers and 40
percent non-smokers and about 93
alcohol consumers versus about seven
percent people that don't consume
alcohol
in addition to that there's 96 percent
of people that had a stroke and about
four percent that did not have a stroke
right so
this just gives us some statistical
understanding of categorical variables
and you can see that
probably
if we have people that are 91 heart
disease and 90 without heart disease
there's a big overlap between people who
are smokers and non-smokers which means
that there's a lot of non-smokers that
have heart disease or there's a lot of
people that are smokers that don't have
heart disease right so these are kinds
of questions that we can start thinking
about as we look at these proportions
in addition to that
you can look at other kinds of uh things
here as well so
uh you you can change for example how
you visualize yes or no right and you
can say among people that have heart
disease how many of them are smokers so
it turns out that
60 percent
of the people
that
have
heart disease are non-smokers
or
84
of the people that have heart disease
also had a stroke right or 66 of the
people
have heart disease and they are diabetic
right and this is an interesting way to
look at it because you see that for
example well 16
did not have a stroke right or
four point seventeen percent don't
consume alcohol right so there's a
proportion of people now if you think
about it four percent of four hundred
thousand is still a significant number
of people so there's a lot of people out
there that don't smoke
don't consume alcohol have not had
stroke and don't have diabetes but yet
have heart disease right and that's why
it's not just a very simple way to
interpret the data just by saying oh
well there's a lot of people that drink
alcohol that have heart disease it must
lead one to another i mean it probably
does but it's more
nuanced than that there's more variation
in our data and that's what we are
finding as we explore the data that we
have
in addition to these categorical simple
categories we also have numeric
variables for example bmi
is a number right and that number is any
on a continuous scale so it can go
anywhere from zero to maybe a hundred
and what you can see here is a histogram
a distribution of values
in each category and so you can see that
you know this is not to confuse with the
numbers of people
each uh so the y-axis represents how
many of those people we have
in each bin right and so you can see
that the distribution is fairly normal
right that's that kind of outcome from
here and the reason you have a much
lower
red than blue is just because you have
so
less people in each category right you
just have nine percent of the people are
in the
heart disease category whereas 90 uh
one percent are in the no heart disease
category right and that's why this might
be a little bit confusing if you just
look at it
now why in the world would we use
principle component analysis to perform
uh this exploratory analysis and so here
briefly i'll explain what principle
component is and why it's useful in this
category as well
well principal component analysis if you
look right here on the right side
basically tries to find such components
in the variance covariance matrix
that maximize variance of
all of our data right so i'm trying to
kind of find such projections in my data
that would explain variance for all of
the data or the majority of the data
that i have
and there are several things to remember
here
number one is that this is very useful
for visualization but not very useful
for actual conclusions about the data
because it doesn't give us a lot of
statistical confidence in what we are
saying it just shows us different
patterns now when we have complex
patterns it's very useful to explore
what those patterns are because we're
looking here at some
kind of reduced dimensionality of the
actual data set right so we're like
looking at the
shadow of the real object and as you can
see on the left when we add multiple
dimensions to this visualization it
starts showing us interesting patterns
for example
in this pca i actually see
four different groups right that have
different patterns inside you can almost
see it right there right different
patterns
uh
right here right it's it's kind of
visible right i have one two three and
four so that means there might be some
batch effect right something that i
might want to look into more like let's
say we have uh you know our age group
separated into four categories maybe
that's what those groups are right and
so i could explore how that impacts what
i am going to get in terms of getting
all the data and one additional insight
that that could give you is maybe we
could separate our data into different
groups and explore them separately if we
want to get better results
so a lot of this analysis actually is
done so that we can find
uh significant
variables features right
that could be
statistically significant in our
analysis and in this case one way to
check a quick check for some
relationship is to build a correlation
matrix so everybody probably knows what
correlation is correlation means that if
one number goes up the other number also
goes up and it's a fairly linear
relationship so a correlation could
range between zero and one and in this
case when we build this correlation
matrix you basically see that most of
these values are uncorrelated and maybe
the top one is the difficulty in walking
and physical health which is a very
intuitive kind of a thing right so you
can see that physical health which is
how you move
and difficulty walking should be
correlated right and so those are the
quick insights that you can get from
here
in addition to that you can get your
typical statistical uh kind of uh
evaluation of each one of your numeric
values like bmi physical health mental
health and sleep time so here you can
see
also age category is associated with
higher chance of heart disease
difficulty of walking and skin cancer
interesting physical and mental health
are slightly correlated right that means
that for some people physical and mental
health are kind of going together right
and so i think that is also expected
all right now as i mentioned we go from
exploring our data and kind of
understanding what is in our data to
trying to define specific groups within
our data that we can cluster together or
we can say these are defined groups that
we want to take to look at further
so let's say we have our principal
component analysis as i see on this side
and here i want to now say i don't want
to just color them by different colors i
actually want to define them and
definition could be done by several
different methods but the objective of
those methods is pretty consistent the
objective is to say that this is
my
groups
and this is the borders of those groups
or maybe these are the specific
relationships within the group right so
how could i evaluate my clustering i
could actually start saying well how
many clusters do i expect there to be
and what if i give that number are the
measurements within and between the
different clusters and that will give me
some conclusive analysis of my data
so in our specific case what we're going
to do is we're going to use several
different methods this is an algorithm
of one of those methods that is called a
hierarchical clustering and and
hierarchical clustering basically takes
a number of points and measures
euclidean distance between them to
organize each group of dots or objects
in our case individuals into bigger
groups and we'll perform that bottom up
so from each individual
each individual in our data all the way
to
one single group
but in reality there are many different
types of methods of clustering and so in
the context of today's workshop we'll
explore just a few of them to get a
sense of how different they are and how
they use different metrics and settings
that could be
appropriate for this
specific use case
so we'll use that we'll look at methods
like k-means birch or agglomerative
hierarchical clustering and we'll look
at density clustering as well in
particular db scan or density-based
scanning clustering and there are some
other ones like grid and model et cetera
we'll not go into those today
so one important thing uh when you deal
with methods of clustering like k-means
or hierarchical clustering is that they
kind of ask you from the beginning well
how do you define the number of expected
clusters or k
and you can say any number i expect two
i expect four i expect 24.
how do you determine where is that
cutoff and when's the appropriate number
of clusters so we'll look today at the
elbow plot where we'll use the
silhouette measure
to determine the number of clusters and
you can use the silhouette or the
inertia for k-means
to find that optimal number or range of
numbers that is appropriate for a data
set
ultimately
once you have performed such clustering
you can see right here is the result
mapped on the principal component you
can start asking specific questions
right for example in the first cluster
or cluster number zero i end up with
uh 99
heart disease and about one percent not
heart disease right and so maybe this
cluster is specific to heart disease
and here i can see proportions of other
types of variables that i might be
interested in
i also have here other
kind of comparisons within other
clusters
and here i can also look at well how
many samples got assigned to a
particular cluster but ultimately i'm
also interested in the separation
between my clusters and i see that the
separation isn't actually not that great
and that's why
in many cases we want to use many
different methods of clustering because
each method of clustering has
an application to more complex data sets
so here you can see this is k-means
clustering this is
a hierarchical clustering the way it
works and here's db scan
and so you can see that db scan can
actually work with more complex patterns
that may be a more simple method like
k-means or hierarchical clustering might
have difficulty working with and so
we'll look at several of those methods
and think how are they useful in this
example
finally we'll talk about classification
so what is classification classification
is when i want to assign
some group of
samples that i have
to a class and then think
how can i train a model to recognize
those examples in an unlabeled data set
in a test data set
what's important here is that i can do
it with simple rules right just like we
saw in clustering i can say well if you
have heart disease and if you're a
smoker and if you have a stroke
then you are more likely to fall into
the heart disease category
now that might be a very simple way of
doing that and depending on where i
start from and where i end i might get
several different results
so that's why we will take a look at
more advanced methods like random forest
which is essentially the same idea but
many different times on several
different bags of data set of data
within my data set
how can i get better results
so here we'll talk about how do we train
a model
how do we
do bagging and bootstrapping and then
finally how do we evaluate the outcome
of our training and here we can look at
several different parameters such as
accuracy precision recall the area under
curve and importantly we'll take a look
at the f1 score or the method to
evaluate how well our model performed
even with the imbalance that we might
have in our data
ultimately we will take a look at going
from a very good model that has high
accuracy over 90
percent precision but nevertheless a
pretty poor f1 score for one of our
classes or the class that actually uh
has heart disease which is what we are
interested in
we'll also look at how to once we have
tuned fine-tuned and kind of uh made a
good model and tested it how can we use
it to evaluate feature significance or
how different features contribute to our
ability to classify that particular
condition
and ultimately
we'll get to our balancing of our model
and how can we use balancing to get a
better
model that could be even further refined
if we start taking apart this data set
and looking within individual cohorts